bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour ce nouveau webinaire alors un petit
peu décalé le live cette semaine et en
fait ça risque d'être un petit peu comme
ça jusqu'à jusqu'à l'été on est dans une
période de déconfinement et du coup de
leysin jada se complexifie un petit peu
en tout cas pas s'écouter cette semaine
nous allons aborder une thématique qui
va nous suivre pendant plusieurs séances
puisque on va aborder un exemple d'
analyse de trajectoire à travers les
trajectoires de soins ces îles ne
d'élise qui adapte et de données réelles
transformé pour devenir des donner
l'exemple mais qui font partie d'un
travail de recherche que j'ai pu mener
et ça va nous permettre d'aborder
différentes techniques avec un même jeu
de données de l'analyse survie de
l'analyse séquence des modèles mix
acacias tentes et d'autres choses un peu
nouvelle et puis on va faire aussi un
petit peu de manipulation un peu avancé
de données et des graphiques un peu
poussé donc je pense que ça va devenir
simple probablement sur deux ou trois
séances mais qui une manière de
reprendre ce qu'on a pu voir sous la
forme d'un exemple concret mais
également de d'aborder deux de nouvelles
choses on est en plus bientôt on voit
que l'été va arriver donc les on va
continuer je vais essayer de continuer
ce rythme toute les semaines où toutes
les deux semaines jusqu'à l'été avant
une pause estivale
sachant que la rentrée prochaine on va
probablement reprendre les luminaires
sous un autre format
en tout cas sur une fois on peut être un
peu plus irrégulières mais sur des
nouveaux sujets que j'ai envie décide
d'aborder j'en remercie celles et ceux
qui ont pris le temps de répondre à la
petite enquête qu'on a qu'on mène à
auprès des utilisateurs des webinaires
sachant que sur les prochaines
thématique ne pourrait pas couvrir toute
votre monde parce que malheureusement il
ya des sujets que je ne maîtrise pas ou
des types d'analystes moi j'ai pas moi
même mené et je ne me sens pas du coup
de présenter des techniques d analyse
qui ne sont pas les miens books est vrai
qu effectivement les exemples que je
donne sont très orientés par rapport à
mes propres recherches
que j'essaye de me baser sur des choses
que j'ai moi même expérimenté d'une
point de vue analytique
alors je vous propose de vous présenter
rapidement les données qui vont nous
servir pour aujourd'hui
première chose pour celles et ceux qui
ne se sont pas inscrits à la mailing
list des webinaires je vous invite
vraiment à prendre le temps de vous
inscrire à la liste de diffusion dédié
pour cela vous avez juste besoin
d'envoyer un e-mail à sympa at least
points et r&d point fr et que l'objet de
votre email contiennent subscribe en
anglais oui bin tirer r c'est ça vous
est indiqué sur la page d'accueil des
webinaires et ça permettra du coup de
vous annoncer les horaires des
prochaines séances et puis les
thématiques qui seront abordées par la
suite ou dans le futur
non vraiment je vous invite à vous à
vous inscrire à cette mailing list pour
être tenu informé des nouveautés
et puis si ce n'est pas déjà fait à vous
abonner à la chaîne youtube puisque du
coup ça vous permet d'être notifiés et
de ce qui arrive sur sur les prochaines
séances sur le site web in r je vous
rappelle que vous avez un menu séance
qui me permet de voir toutes les séances
passées et les prochaines séances à
venir et je mets ouvrir la page
d'aujourd'hui qui va me permettre de
télécharger le jeu de données qui va
nous servir pour aujourd'hui donc
aujourd'hui les jeux de données est déjà
dans un format air avec le fichier
qu'effectue remise points est atteint je
vais faire un clic droit et je vais
enregistrer le fichier et j'ai déjà
préparé un document webinaire
trajectoire de soins j'ai déjà préparé
dans un studio un projet dédié pour
aujourd'hui donc vouliez retrouve ici
les données qui sont reprises
alors petite nouveauté aujourd'hui
plutôt que de faire un script r comme on
l'a vu jusqu'à présent on va innover et
on va faire inscrits au format est marc
daou
alors le format remarque down c'est ce
qui permet de faire des rapports
automatisés dans l air indirectement
c'est ce qui est utilisé pour pour ce
que l'on pour les rapports un peu
automatique
l'idée c'est que on va pouvoir mélanger
du code r avec une présentation avec du
coup des commentaires des choses que
l'on va écrire mettre des titres et tout
ce jour d'éléments à un fichier r marc
damon a donc mélange donc du côté air
avec du marc daoud et le mark damon
c'est ce qu'on appelle un langage de
balisage léger qui permet du coup de
maître en forme du texte de manière
simple dans un document textuelles pour
faire un fichier matin avec un studio
c'est assez facile on va cliquez sur
nouveau et je vais choisir le format est
remarque tard alors je vais déjà
indiquer un titre
pour mon document alors avec un mcdo on
peut faire qu'un type de document là on
va faire le document de base mais sachez
qu'on peut aussi faire des présentations
on peut faire des documents chez mini
l'ensemble du site analysé arrêté créant
et remarques down l'ensemble du cycle
webinaire aussi là je vraiment faire un
document simple je vais indiquer le
titre du document je vais indiqué
l'auteur par défaut vous avez trois
formats différents qui sont le format
html
le format pdf et le format word
alors sachez que le plus simple à
utiliser au quotidien c'est le format
html
mais est on peut toujours basculer
ensuite derrière sur un format pdf on
est sur un format word
sachez aussi que pour faire un format
pdf il faut disposer sur son pc d'une
installation de teck ou de la tech le
plus simple c'est d'installer milk texte
sous windows d'aller télécharger mactech
sur mac os ou thècle arrive sur linux
dans tous les cas c'est un
ça prend un peu de temps à télécharger
et à installer donc fait tsahal il ya
plein tutoriel sur internet sur comment
installer la tech mais déjà je vais vous
présenter à quoi ressemble un document à
magna au jeu cliquer sur ok j'ai du coup
un nouveau document d'accord lui faire
file c'est alors je vais tout de suite
le sauvegarder je vais l'appeler
trajectoire et d'envoyer sam a créé un
fichier trajectoire point m d un script
air qui contient que du code r c'est un
fichier point m un fichier point rmd
c'est un fichier qui contient du marc
darroze md et du code et m le principe
dans un fichier remarque down
vous avez d'abord cette première partie
qui sont ce qu'on appelle des
métadonnées là en l'occurence j'ai un
titre
un nom d'auteur une date et des
informations sur comment le sortir
si au début vous savez pas trop comment
modifier ça vous embêtez pas on va voir
que ça peut se modifier directement
depuis un studio et le format en
question c'est un format un petit pas
typique c'est dit c'est écrire en yaman
désolé c'est encore un nouveau code mais
c'est parti là normalement on pouvait
pas la modifier manuellement
ensuite vous avez parfois entouré alors
c'est qu'au delà je sais pas si vous
voyez ce que à quoi ça ressemble c'est
en fait c'est un accent grave on obtient
d'ailleurs sur un pc windows avec alger
recettes d'accord est en fait 3 accent
grave à 3 accent grave ça fait ce qu'on
appelle un look de code qui est rendu
alors acheté belle comme du code et si
on navigue entre crochets l'apathie tête
r ça veut dire c'est du colère qui m'a
est exécuté oublions ça qu'on moment
vous avez ensuite du texte donc là
si les double diez indique que c'est un
titre de niveau 2 vous avez du texte qui
est décrit un lien qui a indiqué entre
crochets un mot qui indiquait en gras
avec des 12 étoiles et pyrénées on va
remettre un bloc de code r avec du code
exécuté vous voyez c'est un document ou
textuelles avec des a's éléments de mise
en forme
l'intérêt c'est que si je clique sur le
bouton cnit ça va me rées exécuté
l'ensemble du document et ça va me
produire un fichier html qui contient
l'ensemble des éléments sa exécuté mon
code
ici ça m'a mis le graphique obtenu 1
donc on a tous les éléments et ça a
généré ici un fichier point htm
si j'avais voulu plutôt un document word
avec la petite flèche à côté du bouton
cnit j'aurais pu faire quitte ou gold
est donc là
savard exécuté l'ensemble du code et je
récupère un document word et voyez les
kits sont inclus comme des titres dans
bob donc ça va offre en fait beaucoup
plus de possibilités pour faire quelque
chose de propre et efficace et enfin je
peux dire que need to pdf ce que ça fait
dans ces cas-là ça process le document
alors en fait ce que fait unitaire pour
bien comprendre ça prend le document ça
exécute le code r pour produire un
document markdown et ce document
markdown est ensuite transformé en html
pour word et quand on veut faire un
fichier pdf
ça va le transformer en un document la
tête puis le transformer en un pdf les
documents intermédiaires n'apparaissent
pas par contre voici le document pdf
obtenu autre élément si je veut modifier
la manière dont nos documents va être
rendue vous avez le petit bouton ici
avec la roue dentée si je clique dessus
ça m'ouvre un autre coup troc jumelage
et l'option à [ __ ] auctions et là je
peux choisir des options par exemple je
veux le sortir dans un format html mais
j'aimerais avoir une table des matières
je voudrais dire que la taille par
défaut des figures c'est 8 pouces de
largeur sur 3 pouces de hauteur et si je
clique ici ça va en fait cette partie
d'almeria jour tout seul cette partie
ici qu'un petit peu compliqué à utiliser
je clique sur clint haymon
q mans est maintenant rendue j'ai ma
table des matières qui est présenté ici
alors au début ce que je vous invite
pour vos premiers documents à mark damon
utiliser uniquement les 3 formats de
base html world ans et même si c'est pas
forcément les publics
c'est efficace et ça fonctionne par la
suite vous pourrez aller voir pour
utiliser d'autres package qui propose
des temples est de documents par exemple
le site webinar utilise un temps plein
de documents qui s'appelle distille ici
vous intéresse vous avez dit still here
malte a sonné vous avez un site web qui
vous présente ce qu'on peut faire dans
ce format distille for air malta ont
toutes les options qui sont disponibles
avec des lahoud particulière dit il
prend en compte également peu rang des
équations et on peut même y intégrer des
références bibliographiques
vous avez également rmd formate qui est
un package de julien barnier et qui
propose des template de documents html
par exemple le temple it would turn et
vous avez ici un exemple de documents
qui est construit avec cette emplette
voyez vous avez une table des matières à
deux niveaux dans la colonne de gauche
et a rendu qui est plutôt propre
en fait on peut faire beaucoup beaucoup
de choses à cape town dites vous que
c'est quelque chose qui est intéressant
à apprendre et aller progressivement
ce qu'il faut aussi savoir c'est que on
peut même aller plus loin
alors vous avez un document essentiel
qui est et remarques down définitive
kaid qui est un livre qui vous présente
marque d'haroun en long en large et en
détail
donc c'est un livre entier qui
accessible gratuitement en ligne
et sachez que ce livre est lui-même
écrit en marque down grâce à un package
qui s'appelle au garonne et qui permet
d'écrire des livres en entier
et vous avez aussi un site dédié qui
s'appelle r marc down qui va vous
présenter toute une série de choses qui
peuvent être faits avec un marteau et un
servant d'introduction d'envoyer et
remarques down c'est vraiment un outil
puissant qui va servir de manière large
à cliquer donc faire énormément de
choses
revenons néanmoins nourrir studio pour
des éléments de base
donc vous avez un premier document et je
peux modifier son texte par exemple vous
réécrire une nouvelle partie donc je
vais écrire un titre de niveau 2 donc je
vais écrire du texte avec de l'italique
et du grain la manière en fait qu'on a
décrit du texte final on oubli pur
moment la partie conair intérieur en
fait c'est avec un formatage léger les
kits syndic avec des dièses en début de
ligne
un des sportifs de niveau 1 de diaspora
ti de niveau 2 3 10 pour un titre de
niveau iii etc
on va indiquer les italiques avec des
astérisques du gras avec des doubles *
est par exemple si je vais faire une
liste eh ben je vais commencer une
nouvelle partie je fais un item un item
deux items 3 si je fais tu mixes
alors on va faire racheter maintenant
c'est le plus rapide
le texte que j'ai écrit va être mise en
forme maintenant donc le marc daoud
c'est cette partie mise en forme de
texte alors le marc daou n'est pas
forcément très compliqué à prendre fois
juste en fait au début voir un peu
comment quelques raccourcis en premier
lieu dans le menu alpes
vous avez marc daoud quick référence
ça vous affiche directement ici à droite
la plupart des les principaux les
principaux raccourci l'italie qui se
fait avec dender score ou avec des
étoiles 5 le gras du double les types de
niveau 1 de niveau 2 de niveau 3 des
listes monodor ordonné ou ou des listes
numérotées comment écrire un lien donc
soit du texte plein qui va être
automatiquement transformés soit texte
du lien entre crochets puis entre
parenthèses l'url julien comment m
comment mettre des images et comment
écrire du connaugh là vous avez la
plupart des raccourcis de base et vous
avez plus d'informations avec le lien
using et remarques down mais il n'est
pas forcément nécessaire de tout
apprendre car depuis les dernières
versions de leurs studios
si vous prenez la toute dernière version
de la studio vous avez ce bouton ici qui
permet de basculer dans un éditeur
visuel de marque down c'est je clique
dessus
là je vois directement m'ont rendu
je peux rajouter indienne de liste et si
je le veux le passé en gras normalement
j'ai un bouton gras alors ils sont pas
forcément là bien visible mais vous
allez bouton gras italique souligné
éléments du code qui malheureusement la
seule capture d'écran sont pas bien
visibles et donc du coup on peut
facilement écrire en fait ces éléments
au fur et à mesure un peu plus fous si
vous utilisez zotero pour gérer votre
base bibliographique
il est même possible de faire des
citations comme je le disais et je vais
me citez moi même
m soyons fous inseps situation alors je
vais dire depuis ma librairie zotero je
vais chercher jusque jour écrit un
article d'une collègue où je suis co
auteur alors je vais je vais rechercher
ma référence je vais cliquez sur win7 et
du coup ça va s'être connectés que mme
otero et ça va normalement mains serrées
ma référence
bien sûr qu'est ce qui s'est passé ça
fait de fichiers référence à une la
municipale oui on peut passer
l'ayant fait du mode éditeur visuel au
mode classique et on peut rajouter des
tables des images ça va directement vous
générez le code et remarques d'haroun de
base d'accords donc on peut utiliser ce
mode là au tout début ici on connaît pas
bien par exemple je peux faire un
tableau avec trois que deux colonnes et
trois lignes d'accord et puis on va
taper différents items à l'intérieur si
je sors du mode éditeur visuel on voit
un ici directement que c'est en train de
c'est en train de de générer le code
correspondant à un tableau mais c'est un
code qui faire à la main un peu
compliqué donc c'est plus facile de
passer par les toits vivait alors une
des questions qui est posée dans le chat
c'est pour comprendre l'intérêt de la
marque down pouvez vous nous indiquer
vos usages du 1er mars down écrivez-vous
des articles anti en l'air marie donne
par exemple
alors j'écris pas vraiment d'articles
antilles et la parole de la question des
références bibliographiques
c'est quelque chose que j'utilise peu
par contre j'utilise le r marc daoud
pour toutes mes analyses
c'est à dire que j'utilisais script r
quand il s'agit du code d'importation
nettoyer h en formation pour créer dans
mais dans mes projets je pars de données
brutes et on va créer des fichiers de
données recoder propre bien documenté
donc en général là on va mal c'est moi
je passe par du code r par contre dès
lors qu'il s'agit d analyse je passe par
un fichier remarche la zone parce que ça
me permet d'en marquer mes propres
commentaires sous les analyses et la
production de graphiques et tableaux je
fais en général des amap down au format
html c'est le format de base que je
déguisés pour mes analyses par contre
souvent dans mon domaine de publication
ce que je dois envoyer avec hauteur
c'est plutôt un document word pour que
plus les uns les autres
faire les lits thing la revue demande un
fichier mois donc en fait je vais plutôt
faire en sorte au fur et à mesure de
l'année d'avoir un fichier marc down qui
contient toutes les sorties nécessaire
pour mon article
toutes les images tous les tableaux par
contre la partie rédactionnelle parce
que je bascule ensuite dans un mode de
rédaction collaborative à plusieurs voix
je vais plutôt le faire dans word
parce que dans mon domaine c'est plutôt
world qu'utilisait par les revues avec
lesquels je travaille ou par mes
collaborateurs donc je distingue ces
deux aspects ceci étant dit pour
d'autres usages
le site analyse r il est intégralement
écrire à la marque d'haroun parce que
ces deux formats qui reste le plus
intéressant ce qui est certain c'est que
toute la partie d'un meeting cela fait
toujours du mal down je ne le fais pas
dans les critères de base
l'autre élément qui est là on va voir
comment on va intégrer
du coup le colère dans le hamac down il
faut savoir qu'un code un fichier amar
daoud a exécuté canton l'exécutent
depuis le début et donc du coup ça
m'oblige à être certains permis de pour
exécuter une analyse entièrement c'est
comme quand on fait pour exécuter un
script entièrement est ce qui permet du
coup d'avoir quelque chose de propre
alors autre élément du marc daraud non à
vue on peut mettre du coup du texte
dedans on peut mettre des références
bibliographiques on peut aller assez
loin
et puis surtout à pouvoir mettre du code
r donc là vous avez un exemple de code r
et puis à d'autres endroits on va
vouloir remettre un bloc de code ça ce
qu'on appelle un choc dans le monde de
marie down et vous avez ce bouton la
insert new gods chuck alors vous pouvez
mettre du code dans différents langages
dont il faudra se contenter uniquement
de faire du co2 est d'accord
et quand j'ai un switch d'accord je vais
par exemple j'avais créé une variable x
contient 2 + 3 et puis je vais calculé
log 2x au carré
si je veux je vais exécuter tout ce choc
là j'ai ce petit bouton ici d'accord
wang qishan qui amusait le raccourci de
contrôle chiffres c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est quand je suis en phase
de rédaction d'accord quand j'exécute
and check je vois directement le
résultat qui met pré-visualiser ici
juste en dessous d'accord et ce qui me
permet du coup de développer au fur et à
mesure et puis à la toute fin je vais
cliquez sur qnx pour produire pour
reproduire du début quelque chose de
propre et vous voyez j'ai mon nouveau
code qui est donc là une grosse
différence entre les deux espèces et
qu'il a ce que vous avez si une
prévisualisation qui se fait à partir de
la console et en fonction de ce qui est
à ce moment là en mémoire d'accord alors
que quand je re exécute et je fais un
petit on redémarre d'une session airs
vierge qui va recharger tous les
éléments un par jeu on a en plus des
options pour nos chums qui sont globaux
alors il ya énormément d'options qui
existent ne peut dire par exemple si on
veut afficher ou ne pas afficher le code
si on veulent évaluer si on veut changer
la taille d'une figure donc ce qu'on va
voir s'il ya quelque chose qu'on va
pouvoir faire les changements
progressifs de là en général c'est pour
ça que les premiers jo on va définir les
options global là par défaut vous avez
échos égale clou ça veut dire que le
code est visible dans le rendu on voit
code résultats comme résultat mais il
est aussi possible soit de changer les
paramètres pour un seul chèque comme ici
écho égal face ça peut dire juste pour
ce choc là je ne veux pas affiché est le
paramètre se modifie pour un check
alors soit vous connaissez tous les
codes y en a beaucoup soit vous cliquez
sur la petite roue ici vous avez la
plupart des options
et donc là on avait michaud outputs
ennuis et si je mets aux documents de
défaut ça supprime l'option pour ce choc
là ça sera juste
l'option général qui va être utilisé si
vous voulez connaître tous vous avez ici
un lien vers la page de documentation du
package autoritaire et qui présente
toutes les options possibles ayant fait
fuir énormément ont gardé ça pour plus
tard là on va vraiment faire un premier
de chaque de base d'accords et quand je
change une option au global par exemple
ici j'ai fait écho égal aux femmes
j'obtiens un document où il n'y a plus
de code visible il n'y a que des
résultats alors ça à vous de voir si
vous avez besoin de garder qu'un doute
falgarde écoles pour ma part des
documents qui sont plus techniques ou
plus un thème ou avec un petit groupe de
collaborateurs qui fait aussi l'écho
derrière je vais garder le code visible
parce que c'est un document de travail
puisse avoir est de voir ce code
résultat que de résultats dans d'autres
cas pour d'autres analyse où j'ai
partagé des collaborateurs mais qu'ils
seront moins sur la partie connais on
veut plutôt discret des résultats je
vais masquer le code parce qu'il n'a pas
et forcément être intéressant et qu'il
est plutôt préférable pour eux de voir
uniquement mes tableaux et d'avoir un
document qui a les tableaux les
résultats tout dépend en fait à qui je
vais dessiner mon document ce que je
fais aussi c'est parfois on fait souvent
mes articles je vais faire pour être
honnête plutôt que de faire un fichier
que j'appelle trajectoire en général des
gens et fait ainsi partie de choses pour
tout vous dire pour ma part en général
je vais faire plutôt un document que
j'ai appelé trajectoire 0 1 qui sera la
version une de travail sur cette analyse
là et puis peut-être qu'à un moment
donné j'ai me dire là je vais partir sur
une autre voie je vais la reprendre un
peu différemment et je fais le river 0,2
mais comme ça je regarde du coup 1
mon code de la vie 0 1 parce que très
souvent il ya une première étape
exploratoire on va faire les choses en
plein de directions différentes pour
expérimenter et puis petit à petit je
vais voir plus clair sur qu'est-ce que
j'ai besoin ou 1
comment je veux le faire et ensuite je
vais faire une nouvelle version une fois
que je suis proche de la publication
pour avoir un document propre qui ne
contient plus que ce que je vais garder
haut niveau final donc mon habitude du
coup c'est bien numérotés avec un v 01
et puis de faire un enregistré sous au
moment où je veux changer à autre chose
alors on va revenir ici je fais supprimé
pour moment la partie bibliographiques
parce qu'il va qu'une au service et dans
les options global
je suis définir mais figure pour avoir
une taille par défaut plus standard 8
ans auteur si son argent et puis tu
l'air effacer tout le reste
pour commencer à partir sur l'analyse
qui m'intéresse est comme ça a été un
document le travail qu'on va se partager
je vais garder l'option échos égal et on
va du coup selon c'est dans les analyses
alors en général à l'étape première
étape 1 avant de commencer j'ai toujours
une partie de mise en place des choses
donc je vais créer un premier check sur
lequel je vais charger un certain nombre
de package qui vont me servir tout au
long de l'analyse donc là on va déjà
prendre de base le tailles diverses
il a mad et puis quoi stoner s'est on va
partir sur les paquets de l'est même
package qu'on n'a jusqu'à présent ils
puissent a par exemple
[Musique]
donc là on va l'exécuter et puis je vais
charger les données donc les données
elles sont dans pierre trajectoire mise
alors petite chose importante lorsqu'on
écrit un fichier et remarques down le
chemin que l'on indique et donc pas
relatifs au projet 1000 est relatif aux
fichiers alors la trajectoire et qu'une
frange qui ont mis ce sont tous les deux
la racine de mon répertoire
mais c'est quand vous travaillez avec
des sous répertoires et que vous auriez
un fichier des analyses et ben et des
sous répertoire est en fait il faudrait
le chemin relatifs aux fichiers amateur
et non pas le chemin relatifs à la
racine de votre répertoire de travail
ceci étant dit nous avons déjà chargé
toussaint d'accord et on va commencer
par faire une à les premières
descriptions des données pour voir
beaucoup aidé
alors déjà regardons ce qui s'est passé
lorsque j'ai chargé quatre injections
mise
ça m'a chargé un fichier qui s'appelle
crj hector ruiz en mémoire de 49 1365
observations de huit variables et si on
regarde quel est l'objet en question
vous avez un tableau datar frame est
conforme à d'atteindre pour le terreau
alors data protégeons nous n'avons pas
encore abordé c'est un package qui est
bien pratique quand on rentrait sur des
très très gros fichiers de données
vous avez un chapitre d'analysé qui vous
présente date a pointé bros nous allah
ce stade là ce qui nous intéresse on va
travailler avec lou tailles diverses
donc première chose que l'on va faire on
va le transformer notre jeu de données
en a en un type classique et pour ça on
va tout simplement passer par la
fonction à thibault donc je vais juste
dire que quelqu'un lecture is ces has
thibault
de kate jack tobin est donc qu'à
trajectory maintenant est devenu un
petit bug
si je râle car sa classe on est dj ftp
est d'attaqué pour festoyer à la
conversion d'un format à l'autre est
relativement simple
regardons excusez moi regardons
rapidement ce tableau dans le visualise
dans le dans le dans le viewer ce qui
est à retenir c'est qu'on a plusieurs
variables d'accord et la plus verte et
de la plupart des variables sont codées
sous forme numérique sauf la variable
qui a statué qui connaît sous forme
textuelle et je vais revenir après
circulation ces variables et si on
regarde plus précisément ici on voit
qu'ils les étiquettes derrière et donc
la plupart des variables sur des
variables labellisé un bon saint jacques
attali labellisé avec la bndes donc ça
on sait faire et ça nous permettra d'y
avoir recours
mais on voit qu'on aura quelqu'un va
nous servir maintenant quelles sont les
différentes barrières que nous avons on
peut déjà faire appliquer look fort sur
kurt sorge hector ruiz
c'est une manière de voir les données
telles qu'elles sont au tout début on
voit qu'on a une variable pâlichonne
inactifs aia qui est un entier une
variable mois depuis le diagnostic qui
est une variable numérique une variable
krstic qui a un statut dans les soins
avec des codes des cts
je viendrai mais qui sont à klose buntin
care in care not not and treatment and
treatment butt
[Musique]
patine in fiction nature prince et en
jeans ultra thin factions et enfin on a
deux trois autres variables murphy mais
pour le sexe l'âge le niveau d'éducation
le le niveau de richesse et enfin la
distance à la clinique la plus proche
côté sous une forme binaire alors une
première manière de voir nos données
c'est tout simplement on peut faire un
tableau un triangle à chacune des
variables et pour ça on sait qu'ils
critiquent d'utiliser le pack creech j
tilly sommellerie
donc on va le chercher en mémoire je
vais créer à nouveau le choc ici
alors pour que les variables qui sont
labellisés et je vois que tu mets variés
mme labellisé en fait sont des variables
catégorielles soient reconvertis en
facteurs je vais tout simplement
utiliser la fonction elle la belle que
j'ai appliqué surtout le tableau puisque
jetty sama j'étais sur ma vie attend est
les marques catégorie a soit sous forme
de facteurs et puis on va faire chibi
elle se marie et donc ça
directement mon tableau de tri à plat
retenez que en plus tibet elle se marie
a pris en compte vous avez vu dans le
confort qu'elles avaient toutes un une
étiquette de variables qu'elles sont
prises en quote part tibial second
combat une première description un peu
générique de nous donner
alors ça va parler de répondre à une
première question
j'ai souvent du mal à avoir un bon rendu
des tableaux complexe avec la marque
danone par exemple se produire que le
package table et la fonction tabula si
vous étiez jetty se marie je vous fais
le rapport et remarques down les
tableaux de justice marie font des
tableaux très propre et qui sont très
bien rendus dans un fichier herman d'art
les tableaux de jean marie voyer sortent
parfaitement bien
sinon si vous voulez faire des tableaux
on les remarque down et elle est un
petit peu plus loin il yad'autres ya
plein d'autres extensions qui existe
mais on va plutôt utilisé dans ce cas là
la fonction câble fourni avec mon père
le paquet et jusqu'à d'extra il y en a
d'autres
alors si on va sur un analyseur je vous
invite à aller faire un tour du côté
d'eux dans le chapitre sur le format à
l'armada rhône où vous avez toute une
partie sur le rendu des tableaux
d'accord est en fait les tableaux vous
faites avec ta boîte à bulles à rouler
passé à la fonction câble du package
critères qui va les transformer en vrai
tableau
si vous voulez aller plus loin yann gîte
ismaily il ya surtout qu'à l'extra qui
permet de faire des choses également
poussé par exemple ce genre de tableau
on les extensions jt qui est la
grammaire des tableaux qui en fait
l'équipe de la studio qui a développé
ggp l'un d'eux en train de développer
une extension de jti pourquoi mais j'ai
beau essayer d'ailleurs que là que vient
le dj this mari qui utilise du coupage
aurait tellement le package gt mais
j'étais aujourd'hui
très bien compatible des tableaux au
format word ou au format pdf et donc du
coup dans ces cas là va proposer
d'autres choses dans tous les cas vous
avez énormément des tensions qui
existent pour présenter des tableaux
retenez en tout cas qu'avec justice mal
oui ça va tout seul
et sinon à les regarder du côté de
câbles et le quart l'extra revenons un
bon jeu de données d'accord donc si je
reviens sur le jeu de données
c'est moi maintenant vous présenter les
enquêtes et études
on a utilisé ce que nous avons ici c'est
une étude qui a suivi dans une
population ou ont été mis en place des
campagnes dépistage massif du vih et
dans cette population là on a suivi des
patients à partir du moment où ils ont
été diagnostiqués pour une pathologie
grave et chronique alors en l'occurrence
ici le vih et on a suivi leur parcours
de soins autrement dit on c'est à partir
du moment où ces gens ont été dépistés
s'ils sont rentrés dans les soins est ce
qui s'est passé derrière donc on a leur
suivi mois après mois et donc c'est la
variable créa states donc ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que le fichier plana c'est
une ligne par passion et par mois donc
on a 49 1365 observation c'est moi à
science suivi mais il ya moins de
patients que ça puisque si je prends à
la variable qui est injectée rhuys idée
qui est l'identifiant du patient je
compte avec unique le nombre de valeurs
différentes et comprend lines pour avoir
la longueur de tout ça on à 2929
personnes d'accord donc ces 2009 129
personnes qui sont suivis au cours du
temps mois après mois et on regarde leur
statut dans les soins par défaut au
début ils vont être diagnostiqués mais
ils sont pas encore entrés dans les
soins ils peuvent rentrer dans une
clinique
c'est le status et le patient est entré
dans les soins il est suivi dans son
king
mais il n'a pas commencé encore de
traitement c'est à dire que il est
arrivé dans la clinique
d'accord il est encore une étape on va
faire un bilan initial
il n'a pas encore initié le traitement
ça peut être aussi le cas de figure de
personnes qui vont démarrer un
traitement et qui vont arrêter leur
traitement
elles arrêtent leur traitement mais
elles sont toujours dans les soins elles
seront donc dans ce status in care not
one shot not
si jamais elles sortent de soins
d'accord elles vont redescendre statut
diagnosed huntington parmi les patients
qui sont dans les soins d'accord ils
vont démarrer un traitement et l'intérêt
du traitement
d'accord c'est de contrôler l'infection
en l'occurrence dans cas du vih on va
regarder la charge virale est le but
d'un traitement antirétroviral
c'est de faire en sorte que la chance
générales deviennent indétectable où on
dit encore contrôlés ou supprimées donc
un 3-1 83e statut c'est la personne et
sous traitement
mais l'infection n'est pas supprimé
enfin dernier statut possible old shit
man and processing fiction c'est si la
personne a commencé son traitement et
elle va du coup atteindre ce stade où le
sérieux et à avancer
on a donc quatre statues qui sont dans
les données sont codées en dc ts dacor
est ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que ces statues sont ordonnées on peut
vraiment voir ça comme des étapes
différentes
s'il y avait quelqu'un prend son
traitement mais que l'affection à un
rebond il va repasser du statut est au
stade chuté mais voilà tous les statuts
sont bien les uns au-dessus des autres
on est vraiment sur une variable
catégorielles ordonné hiérarchiquement
et ça va avoir son importance pour la
suite des analyses
on dispose enfin d'autres variables le
sexe de l'individu qui ne changent pas
encore du temps
l'âge est ici les données sont triés
entre les 16-29 ans les 30 59 ans et les
60 ans et plus mais si quelqu'un change
classe-c de classe d'âge au cours du
suivi à ce moment là les données qu'ils
sont observés mois par mois
on se met à jour vous avez le niveau
d'éducation primaire et secondaire louis
ailleurs donc primaire secondaire ou
supérieur
et enfin les ménages ont été catégorisés
en trois groupes de richesse les ménages
les plus pauvres casse moi il ya une
classe supérieure à partir de données de
des biens possédés par le ménage et
enfin vous avez en fonction de là où big
la personne est ce qu'elles habitent à
moins 10 km plus de 10 kilomètres de la
clinique la plus proche
toutes ces variables là sont dites
dépendantes du temps dans le sens où si
quelqu'un des ménages ou si la situation
de la personne change par exemple
changement de groupe d'âge ou des
personnes jeunes des personnes qui vont
rentrer diversité les variables sont
actualisés donc je vous remontre comment
se présente on donne est d'accord là
vous avez pour un premier patient qui le
patient 3 vous avez sa situation
am zéro c'est à dire au moment du
diagnostic
sa situation à m 1 c'est à dire un mois
après le diagnostic quelle est sa
situation sa situation m 2 sa situation
m3/an 4 et n 5
lena toutes les autres variables ici
n'ont pas changé mais elles peuvent être
actualisée au fur et à mesure alors une
petite disque une petite question dans
le chat c'est le bouton une pauvre
dataset fonctionne tin oo un script
ermac down oui et non c'est à dire si
vous utilisez le bouton il porte des
traces est on pour importer un fichier
css par exemple et vous cliquez
sur une porte si vous cliquez sur une
porte sa exécute la commande sauf que ça
ne marchera pas dans votre fichier ahmad
harun parce que un fichier est
remarquable quand vous faites mythe créé
exécute toutes les commandes depuis une
session vierge et donc du coup les
commandes qui ne sont pas dans le script
ne sont pas exécutées mais c'est la même
chose qu'on fait inscrire terre si vous
cliquez sur l'époque dataset vous
exécutez la commande mais vous la copier
pas dans le script si vous redémarrer
une nouvelle session ont redémarré
depuis le début ça ne marchera pas par
contre vous pouvez utiliser le la
fonction ils portent dataset pour
récupérer le code copier le code et à
les copier le code dont un script
d'accord donc en fait si c'est pour
générer le code la fonction marche
si jamais c'est vous l'avez pas recopier
retenez bien une session un fichier un
mac download doit pouvoir s'exécuter
tout seul et être exécuté depuis le
début à partir à partir de l'institut
elle d'une d'une situation vierge
d'ailleurs pour vérifier que tout
fonctionne bien vous avez une option
dans session qui est restée à terre l
world trucks ça vous permet de
redémarrer air et de redémarrer une
session vierge et d'exécuter tous les
blocs de code les uns après les autres
vous voyez d'ailleurs que la progression
est affichée par des petits traits
envers vous voyez en fait l'évolution de
votre code
l'évolution globale est indiqué en bas
et ça vous permet du coup d'avoir une
vue globale de l'avancé
alors ce qu'on veut voir je voulais dit
on a du coup on a donc pour retenir on
peut écrire un peu de commentaires donc
le fichier on tient entourent x ligne
une par individu et par moins de suivi
ce que j'aimerais c'est pouvoir
ici m le résultat est donc le nombre de
lignes 1 c'est qu'elle a purgé que c'est
elle aura au 2 quai 3 octobre lisent ce
que je vais faire
on peut insérer ce qu'on appelle du code
r inline dire au milieu de mon texte
et ça ce fait avait alors accent grave
accent grave donc ça je le fais avec alt
gr septe je vais indiqué air pour dire
là ce que je mets en place c du code r
et je vais confier mon code de la même
manière
l'amitié qui correspond à l'individu
différents vous vous souvenez 1
la commande pour avoir le nom d'un
individu différence était bloquée après
lecture isaïe dit l'unique lines et donc
je vais reprendre ce morceau de code là
vous voyez les blocs de 3 accent grave
ce sont des blocs de code complet et
quand on va juste mettre un tout petit
morceau de code qui va être au milieu
d'un texte on utilise du in line code et
ça se fait avec accent grave air espace
le code et accent grave à la fin si je
fais cnit à ce moment là où il faut
parce que du coup ça ridicule pour un
lit des tic ont fait le cnit à la toute
fin
quand on a une analyse complète vous
avez le fichier contient en tout oui ici
le cône est exécutée et apparaît à
l'intérieur alors une toute première
étape dans mon analyse va être bien de
déjà de savoir là on voit qu'on a c'est
c'est 2929 perse individus qui sont
observés un certain nombre de mois
alors petite précision dans ce fichier
là et on le sait parce que la
documentation de l'anc est multi dont
vous aurez pas aller vérifier par vous
même c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'autre ou
dont suivi les individus certains été
suivi trois mois d'autres ont été suivis
40 mois parce qu'en fait ils n'ont pas
été diagnostiqués au même moment dans le
dispositif
certains ont migré donc on a arrêté le
suivi donc on a une durée de suivi
différentes
par contre il n'ya pas de prudence suivi
ce qui veut dire que si un individu a
été suivie pendant 18 mois
il ya bien toutes les observations entre
0 et 18 et du coup on a donc en fait ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que ils sont
tous observent les comme on parle de la
davie l'anoci qui sont tous observé
depuis diagnostic
donc on a seulement une censure à droite
il ya pas de trou dans le suivi mais
tous tempête a suivi la même durée donc
ce qu'on aimerait regarder quand même
c'est le nombre le nombre d'individus à
chaque étape
donc le nombre d'observations pour mieux
savoir finalement aux prêts selon les
données qu'on a donc ce qu'on va faire
ici je vais faire un nouveau check
on va faire un graphique gfr g1j pilote
qui est en charge actuelle vise ce que
je veux c'est représenter combien j'ai
une observation dans chaque mois je veux
simplement mettre du coup le mois on x
et rajouter gmbh à la ce que j'obtiens
d'accord j'ai un graphique qui on voit
bien que le nombre de personnes suivies
au cours du temps diminue on a beaucoup
de gens qui ont été observés au moins un
an et puis on voit qu'il ya une vraie
déperdition par la suite et on a
finalement très peu de gens qu'on
observait plus 36 mois voire presque
quatre ans un des gens que j'avais 80 en
a très peu et donc on a une déperdition
assez rapide du nombre de gens observé
par contre ce que j'aimerais faire c'est
quand même pour avoir avoir un graphique
tout joli et donc on va faire plusieurs
améliorations à nos graphiques
déjà on a une variable un statut dans
les soins donc du coup on va remplir en
fonction de la variable qui s'appelle si
je regarde mon fichier savent à quel
stade joseph la file égard le caire 7
était ce donc là avec ce graphique on va
voir maintenant les résultats au cours
du temps sauf que plutôt que d'avoir
cdst j'aimerais plutôt à voir leur
étiquette dont je vais appliquer tout
factor à la volée et je vais avoir les
étiquettes
je vais tout au long de tout au long en
fait de ce qu'on va voir je vais
utiliser une palette de couleurs un
petit peu mieux pour présenter mes
résultats
alors je vous en présenter une nouvelle
qu'on n'avait pas encore vu qu'elle a
une couleur qui proposait par viridis
donc pour ça il faut que je charge le
package ville et dix ans mais moi et je
vais pouvoir utiliser ce qu'est fils
viridis est-ce qu'il va pas qu'est ce
qu'il me dit disco être variés sont
plight continue mon score
ça fait longtemps que je n'ai pas fumé
[Musique]
faut indiquer discrète et gallucio en
fait on peut appliquer cette peine de
couleurs à la fois pour on peut
appliquer cette palette de couleurs à la
fois pour des valeurs continuent et à la
fois pour des valeurs discrète
là on est à l'heure des scrutins en
vingt quatre statues donc j'apprécie
visite médicale choquant je l'appelle et
donc la halle est vérifié c'est une
palette de couleurs qui qui qui qui crée
un des gradés qui part du jaune ou bleu
foncé
l'ecc a été développé par des je crois
que c'était les élites de matelas
bloquer les particules et est développé
pour maximiser son passage en noir et
blanc les contrastes et donc là je
retiens bien du coup une palette
progressive mais en même temps on
distingue bien les différents statuts
sauf que là vous voit que ceux qui sont
à l'étape ultime sous traitement avec
une infection control et sont en jaune
clair et ceux qui sont pas encore dans
les soins sont enfoncés moi j'aimerais
plutôt montre l inverse c'est à dire se
dire que ceux qui sont pas encore
annoncés loin dans les soins ils sont
plutôt claires
et foin c'est au fur et à mesure j'ai
juste rajouté l'option breeders
maintenant direction on sait direction
dans le cas présent direction - 1 1 qui
permet du coup d'inverser le sens de la
palette de couleurs on va aussi tout de
suite passé la légende en bas donc
legends
rosich égale bottom et voyez là les bars
il ya des petits traits la côte à côte
ce que je vais essayer de faire c'est
que je vais changer ici et je vais faire
brive égal 1 pour faire en sorte que mes
barres soient collées les unes aux
autres
mais pour rendre visible par contre je
vais redessiné un trait au tour et donc
j'ai simplement indiqué color et gagnent
50 donc c'est un gris avec c'est
vraiment au milieu
et puis on va aller j'ai quand même j'ai
rajouté un thème lights avoir quelque
chose de plus facile à voir
donc là on commence à avoir quelque
chose qui est plutôt pas mal
je vais alléger nos graphiques en
supprimant les étiquettes sur les deux
axes par contre je vais rajouter un
titre alors ces distributions du statut
dans les soins on commence à voir
quelque chose qui est un petit peu un
petit peu mieux alors ceci dit ça
pourrait quand même amélioré
d'une part on voit que les gendarmes
n'arrivent pas trop à la livre donc je
vais rajouter je vais la passer sur deux
lignes pour ça il faut que j'indique
guide dont la fonction guide ans et
celle qui est utilisée pour générer pour
générer et tout ce qui va être les
éléments de légende et donc pour le
paramètre fils
j'ai appelé guide les jeun's et je vais
indiqué je veux la mettre sur deux
lignes avec n 1 euro égale 2 je vais
donner une étiquette correct am a legend
donc là pour le paramètre fils je vais
lui donner comme étiquette statut dans
les soins
et je me rends compte qu'un petit souci
c'est que mes étiquette là elles sont
actuellement en anglais donc je vais
peut-être francisé 1 une partie des
éléments pour gagner un petit peu
entendre j'ai triché
on va retourner sur le chapitre
trajectoire de soins et on avait
normalement
voilà vous avez ici le code que je vais
copié qui permet de changer les
étiquettes deux variables et de valeur
pour avoir du coût des étiquettes en
français je les copier ça et je vais
aller le récupérer dans mon code r je
vais mettre ça tout au début ça permet
de franciser donc j'ai changé les
étiquettes pour quatre lecteurs lisent
pour le sexe pour l'âge pour éducation
est normalement y moment qu'une partie
je dois l'avoir voilà là le code pour
les étiquettes du statut dans les soins
je vais exécuter ce qu au delà
j'ai du coup francisé mais étiquette
normalement si je refais le tableau
je devrais avoir un tableau en entier
alors je me rends compte que ce qu'on
n'a pas changé il ya certaines variables
où j'ai pas changé regarder les
étiquettes
alors on va être on va le faire pour
être les plus propres
donc vers la belle de cuir rouge et or
with english
ça va être identifié a sion la belgique
attendez je vais vous montrer l'autre
syntaxe pour réviser vous savez qu on a
aussi le cette variable il hamels
alors je vous le fais avec l'autre
syntaxe qui a purgé que tu lises cette
variable label ce donc là pour la
variable donc les variables la variable
idées ses identifiants passion pour la
variable mince et moi depuis diagnostic
qu'est ce qui n'a pas encore été traduit
kirstetter statut dans les soins
et la variable waouh au niveau de
richesse
on va refaire notre tableau les voyez
notre tableau était maintenant concise
et alors vous remarquerez probablement
un petit souci c'est que les accents ici
dans l'après vise à sion dans r marc
dallas dans le donateur dont la
prévisualisation dans l'interface de la
studio 1 il a un problème d'affichage
avec les caractères accentués qui
n'apparaissent pas ici correctement par
contre si je gêne hier le rapport final
donc je vais faire le cnit les accents
sont correctement gérées et normalement
dans la version complète est en train de
se calculer un les voyez que les accents
sont cette fois-ci correctement
présentait alors je vois qu'à une
barrière qu'elle avait oublié deux
franchisés qui était du coup la variable
distance
donc on va rajouter donc distance
clinique égale distance clinique la plus
proche et si je regarde le tableau
qu'est-ce que je n'ai pas francisé je
crois qu'il me reste c'est ça donc le
niveau de richesse et la clinique la
plus proche
donc on va reprendre si je regarde là
pour qu'on se remémore commencé qu'au
des quatre j'actualise
fort donc les codes c123 pur bluff
l'oubli de la haye et pour dix ans
clinique c1 et 2 donc la fois ci c d
éthique et de valeurs qu'on va changer
cette niveau la balance donc pour wolf
savait donc pas légal
un moyen légal 2 o 3 et enfin pour
distance clinique
ça va être un moins de dix kilomètres
qui va être égale 1 1 et 10 km ou plus
qu'il va être égal à 2 on voyait comme
toujours la partie préparation de
données pour faire l'état blanc que
preuve à est toujours un petit peu
longue mais là du coup j'ai francisé mes
données
et si je reviens maintenant à mon
graphique qui est ici le statut est
correctement indiqué ici en français on
va quand même essayer d'améliorer encore
un tout petit peu ça parce que l'actuel
mansi genre hier mon étiquette en bas
c'est 0 10 20 30 40 50 mais c'était moi
nous devrait plutôt avoir 06 12 18 24 ce
qui correspond à un petit peu plus
ça fait une étiquette tous les six mois
et puis tant qu'à faire j'aimerais m m
0,1 m6 est une femme 12-0 m6 et le 12ème
18 comme ça j'ai pas besoin d'indiquer
que c'est des mois c'est tout de suite
évident et puis on va rajouter une
petite astuce encore j'aimerais bien
comptés c'est à dire avoir en plus les
effectifs indiqué sur les graphiques
donc là on va vous présenter une petite
astuce déjà on va faire le graphique
tous les six mois
ça se fait avec ce qu'il exprime une
hausse puisque ici c'est une grandeur
numérique et je peux indiquer où est ce
que j'avais mais coupure avec brakes
donc j'aimerais coupé de 0 à 40 8 tous
les 6 48 / si ça vaut 8
donc si je fais 02 points 8 j'obtiens 0
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 6 je fais 02 points 8 x
6 j'obtiens 06 12 18 24 30 36 42 48 qui
sont les endroits où je veux couper mon
tableau graphique dont je vais indiquer
à bréxent manuellement là où je veux
couper on est plutôt pas mal
ce que j'aimerais c'est du coulis mettre
des petites étiquettes dont ce que je
vais faire je vais créer des étiquettes
des six bourgeois que ça l'étiquette
alors premiers éléments à faire le m
devant ces valeurs là on a la fonction
passe 0 qui permet de coller du texte
ensemble dont je vais coller m
avec bas 0,8 fois 6 maintenant si vous
regardez l'objet étiquette étiquette
contient f0 m6 m18 et et compagnie je
peux indiquer dans le squer x continuer
ce je vais dire les étiquettes que
j'avais affiché c'est à belz égal il dit
qu est l'objet de jeux vient de créer et
si vous regardez maintenant gm 0 m6
m-12m 18 et 24 42 48 plutôt pas mal
alors on s'en sort on s'en sort plutôt
bien
maintenant l'astuce ça va être de
pouvoir afficher par dessus le nombre
d'observations donc les effectifs
observé mois par mois
ce que j'aimerais c'est combien utile
d'observer as0 combien de gens à
observer à
m6 combien les gens savaient elles 12
alors si je vais récupérer ça on va déjà
calculé les haines à chacune de ces
dates là donc je prends des requêtes
projecteurs vise je ne veux que c'est un
mois donc je vais félin filter mof in 02
points 8 x 6 donc je retiens que c'est
moins là je vous rappelle un pourcentage
in c est ce que la variable marqué à
gauche et dans une des valeurs qu'on lui
passe donc est-ce que du coup ça
correspond à 0 6 12 18 et compagnie
ce que je veux c'est calculé le nombre
d'observations que j'ai fait râler quand
par mois donc il me faut un groupe by
mince et je rajoute quand
si je fais ça alors un petit truc qui ne
passe pas on a vérifié moi ce que j'ai
fait mais c'est un prof de parenté âge
parce que si je mets mon voilà si je
mets des parenthèses ou tour de 0,2
point ils choisissent pour qu'ils
fassent d'abord se calcule la et
qu'après tout ça il le passe au point où
vont les choses on teste donc quand je
fais ça j'obtiens un tableau d'accord
avec une colonne - une colonne n
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est uniquement
les haines donc j'aimerais extraire une
colonne alors soit j'utilise haine de la
reine
première possibilité où je peux utiliser
la fonction plug qui permet en fait
c'est l'équivalent fait du dollar mais
je peux appliquer directement dans mon
enchaînement avec les pailles et donc si
je fais plock haine ça veut dire extrait
la colonne n
donc si je fais
si j'obtiens un vecteur avec mes
différentes valeurs de haine
du coup dont les étiquettes je peux dire
que ce que je met derrière c'est ouvrait
la parenthèse n égale virgules
m un lieu fermé la parenthèse si
j'aurais exécute tout seul j'ai mon
graphique avec les effectifs mais
problème à envoyer les étiquettes
devient dinars y en a du mal à lire donc
j'aimerais que mettent les haines sur un
retour rajouter un retour à la ligne et
pour rappel le retour à la ligne c anti
slash end donc maintenant mais étiquette
israël 0 retour à la ligne n égale et on
obtient ce graphique l'un est donc là on
voit que on a très peu de personnes
observé un au delà de 4 36 mois on a et
qu'on a cette déperdition assez rapide
et en même temps on voit du coup malgré
tout qu'au début on a quasiment personne
qui est dans les cieux on a très très
peu alors dans la 2 3 qui ont été suivis
qui se sont fait dépister dans une
clinique et le jour même on leur a fait
leur visite d'inclusion qu'en fait ils
sont des héros dans les soins ils sont
très peu nombreux la plupart en fait ont
été dépistés dans des campagnes en
dehors des cliniques donc ils sont le
jour du diagnostic qui sont pas encore
entrés dans les soins mais des entrées
dans les soins qui se font par la suite
et puis même certains ont très
rapidement au moins d'un mois démarrer
un traitement voire même atteindre une
charge virale contrôler sauf que là sur
ce graphique l'art on ne voit pas
ce qu'on voit pas c'est les pourcentages
et donc du coup on aurait tout intérêt
je vais refaire le même graphique mais
cette fois ci en pourcentage et pour ça
je vais recopier le code démographique
il suffit d'indiquer dans gm va position
égale fils
là je suis en pourcentage de petits
éléments 1 je vais vrai pouvoir mettre
du coup les tic est ici en % ça sera un
petit peu plus propre pour ça qu'il va
nous falloir le package inscrire je vais
rajouter ou tout début de mon script est
donc dans mon graphique on va ajouter un
ce qu'il y continue en hausse la baisse
égale vers cents un gîte à la fonction
personnes ce qui est fourni par le
paquet fiscal ce qui fait que on va
afficher des pourcentages sur les bords
et si je veux contrôler pour avoir plus
tôt 20 40 60
je peux indiquer brakes c215 / simple
ces envois 5 / ca 0 à 5 / 5 pour
information ça me fait 0 1 3 4 5 / sonne
ça vous fait directement 0 02 04 06 08
et 1 est donc là j'ai bien les
étiquettes en pourcent alors le titre et
peut-être pas tout à fait légitime
ici on sait depuis la distribution du
statut du moindre pourcentage est en
fait cette répartition de la population
par ce statut c'est ce qu'on appelle la
casquette des soins et donc du coup je
vais donner mon graphique
cascades des soins observé selon le
temps depuis le diagnostic
et puis dernier point quand même il ya
quelque chose qui me ravit ce que d'un
petit peu c'est que là en fait le
graphique qui vient jusqu'à m 48 on voit
qu'on a quasiment plus personne à ce
stade là donc les derniers chiffres ils
sont calculés avec beaucoup
d'incertitudes et d'imprécisions
finalement au lieu à 36 mois il ya là
plus grand chose et donc du coup on
aurait tout intérêt à infiltrer le
graphique et à de garder que les données
avant trente six mois donc je vais
rajouter à cette étape là un petit
filter je vais faire ma meuf inférieure
ou égale à 36 ce qui me permet d'avoir
d'abord à consignes graphique et notre
présenter uniquement ce qui se passe
avant le 36e ans à cette étape là on a
quand même ce qu'il faut retenir il faut
être vigilant c'est que ce que nous
avons ici c'est la casquette des soins
telle qu'elle est observée dans les
données mais ça ne tient pas compte ce
qui se passe et qu'on va bien qu'on n'a
pas le même nombre de gens qui sont
observés à chacun des mois à chaque mois
et donc implicitement condom fait ce
graphique là on fait l'hypothèse que la
durée d'observation n'est pas fonction
et indépendante en fait du statut dans
les soins or on peut faire l'hypothèse
que les personnes qui sont très mobiles
et donc celles qui auraient tendance à
émigrer et du coup à sortir de
l'observation
peut-être qu'elle serait elle aurait
moins tendance non plus à l'est dans les
soins parce qu'on sait que les migrants
souvent moins recours aux services de
santé et donc du coup ceux qui sortent
de l'observation serait peut-être plus
souvent dans le statut diagnostiqués
mais pas suivi
de même ceux qui sortent de
l'observation en cause d'un décès
souvent ils ont été très malade donc ils
vont avoir tendance à haybes rentrer
à l'hôpital à être observées l'hôpital
avant de sortir de l'observation et donc
du coup pareil on doit le statut sous
traitement devrait peut-être être sûr
représenté pour parmi les décédés ce qui
est à retenir en tout cas c'est que
quand on fait ce type de graphique là on
le taille on ne tient pas compte 1,2 des
sorties et que du coup il serait
pertinent d'avoir des techniques
d'analysé un peu plus fines notamment
l'analyse survie qui est celle qu'on
utilise pour reconstruire finalement une
courbe de survie 1dans kaplan meier mais
qui arrive à prendre en compte de
manière plus correct ces censures à
droite c'est à dire que tout le monde
n'ait pas observé
et du coup la semaine prochaine voilà on
a vu la présentation des données la
semaine prochaine on va aborder
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire internalise
de survie classique à partir des données
qu'on a là et on verra notamment
on va faire en fait plusieurs analyses
survie notamment on verra en fait
l'entrée en soins l'initiation du
traitement le contrôle de l'infection et
donc cela va nécessiter de calculer ces
différentes dates et puis on verra du
coup les différentes transition doit
statuer à l'autre on analyse sur les
classiques
sauf que l'année de survie classique et
ben va permettre de prendre en compte
que les premiers transition donc on va
aller un peu plus loin et ont enchaîné
sur une analyse de séquences avec bah du
coup comment se manger un le fait qu'on
n'a pas de durée d'observation qui sont
qui le rendent partout avec hâte alors
on va voir qu'il ya différents types de
trajectoire de soins qui émergent et
donc on va essayer du coup de regarder
les facteurs associés à ces différents
types de trajectoire et bien après dans
les séances suivantes je pense qu'on a
encore moins d'octroi on veut aborder
encore d'autres techniques d'analysés
notamment les modèles mixtes à classe la
tente ou encore à
les modèles observations répétées dans
tous les cas on va s'arrêter là pour ce
soir puisque je crois que ça fait déjà
beaucoup de choses sur cette première
alors c'est vrai qu'on a passé pas mal
de temps comme toujours sur
l'introduction et puis sur le passage du
coup format rnd est ce que je vais faire
à la toute fin
si on va essayer de régler cuts et
d'autres fichiers en entier pour voir
s'il s'exécute bien et donc normalement
quand je fais que need ici ça reprend
une session à elle complètement vierge
essart exécute toutes les commandes si
j'ai bien écrit des choses ça va
s'exécuter
si jamais il ya une erreur quelque part
ça va s'arrêter et c'est un mois les a
identifiés ou est ce que j'ai oublié
quelque chose ou est ce que je revienne
commandes que j'aurais mis dans la
console n'est pas dans mon script mais
là en tout cas on voit que ça s'est
exécuté j'ai bien mon apport qui est là
et donc du coup avec mes graphiques
si je veux le voir de meilleures
manières je peux cliquer sur open et le
browser qui va nous déplacer le fichier
html dans le dans le navigateur web
directement à maintenir une petite
subtilité ce que par défaut ce qui est
produit c'est ce qu'on appelle des
fichiers à une option importante dans
les rades potes c'est dans la devancer
christine delhaise html documents donc
la particularité c'est que les images
vont être encodé directement dans le
fichier html ce qui fait que tout le
code de la page web est stocké dans un
seul fichier alors que dans une page à
la classique en général et les images
sont des fichiers à partager des
références locales mais là c'est pas
pratique du coup envoyé et c'est pour ça
que par défaut on a du coup ces
documents stand alone atx des images
documents ou vous avez un seul fichier
qui contient tout et vous pouvez
facilement envoyer par email
en tout cas écoutez je vous remercie
pour votre attention
on poursuit du coup la semaine prochaine
la semaine prochaine pareil le webinaire
aura pas lieu
jeudi il aura lieu mardi
exceptionnellement à 17 heures c'est et
15h gmt
effectivement j'ai un agenda qui se
complique un petit peu là sur cette fin
mai sur le début du mois de juin
mais comme vous êtes de plus en plus à
ne pas regarder en live mais plutôt à
regarder en différé vous aurez toujours
du coup la vidéo en temps et en heure en
tout cas merci pour votre attention
merci pour tout on se retrouve donc la
semaine prochaine et on va poursuivre
avec les mêmes données à dali de survie
et analyse de séquences merci au revoir
la très bonne semaine à vous tous